hey i'm lars schmeink and today i'll be
breaking down how cyberpunk is portrayed
in video games
[Music]
you might have encountered cyberpunk
when you've watched the matrix
blade runner or blade runner 2049
cyberpunk is a science fiction genre
that deals a lot with corporations
taking over the world
and with how technology kind of becomes
invasive into our bodies the video games
we'll be talking about today
are cyberpunk 2077 watchdogs legion
and deus ex mankind divided along with
other popular games like syndicate
ghost runner deus ex human revolution
and detroit become human
let's take a look at how biohacking is
portrayed in cyberpunk video games
deep net cyberpunk 2077
[Applause]
[Music]
johnny
cyberpunk 2077 calls it the deep net in
william gibson's neuromancer it's called
cyberspace
in neil stevenson's snow crash it's
called the metaverse
and the wachowskis have called it the
matrix but it all basically means the
same thing
a net spread all over the world where
you can access basically every object
every data that is available
where are our we
data fortress bridge to the deep net
in cyberpunk the deep net is usually
geometrical objects
lined up as representations of data
they're flying over this
grid of electronic data points the grid
is actually dominated by an early 80s
movie called
tron which has these objects moving in
straight lines it's actually one of the
most
iconic aspects of cyberpunk you can see
this in the scene
when she hacks in
the room that she's in with the the
other people standing there and the
the ice tub and everything it's all
represented
as data and this is of course the the
same as in the matrix when neo
realizes that he's the one and kind of
goes
into the matrix to shape objects that
are formed of code
so this is kind of the the visual cue
that we have here from two of the
kind of original cyberpunk ancestors so
the idea of actually becoming part of
the computer system going into the
computer system
is appealing in the sense that you're
opening up a completely new world right
so you're not just sitting in your
basement in front of your computer but
you're actually
moving through the world of data and you
can change the world from there i'm not
100 sure
why they do this with the ice tub it's a
new image i've not seen this before
but on the other hand maybe they're just
afraid of you know her body overheating
and
kind of because the processing power is
getting jacked up so high
upgrading cyberpunk 2077 the
dr vector will see you now
we're at a ripperdoc clinic ripperdocs
are specialist vendors
who offer people the possibility to
install or upgrade their
cyberware cyberpunk has a very unequal
society if you are rich you would
probably go to
a high-end clinic but since most
cyberpunk stories actually deal with the
criminal
element in some way and v seems to be
something like a hired criminal
for specific jobs she probably wouldn't
have the ability to go
to a normal clinic or to pay for high
scale
body augmentation so the only choice is
to go to in this case a
ripper dog
ripper with a couple of hooks
get in the upper hand pretty darn
quickly need to bump up my specs and get
a grip
body modifications in cyberpunk are
based on the idea of prosthesis of
amputees we're kind of taking this a
step further
to the idea that certain jobs require
you to be implanted with something
so if you want to do a specific job your
normal
eyesight doesn't actually work anymore
so you would be required to get specific
eyesight or
attach tools to your body because your
body becomes kind of the tool
itself lights out for a minute all right
you might feel a little discomfort maybe
blurred vision
low contrast glitches
so how's it look to you
with the scanner we can zoom in on
things and take a closer look
that ought to work like a charm
now draw your weapon you should see your
ammo count in a brand new
site in the scene we do see two
different kinds of augmentations
on the one hand we do see the ripper
docs augmentations which
are very mechanical he has kind of tools
in his arm
which he uses for his work on the other
hand you see
these implantations or these
augmentations a dermal implant is
actually just like a
a glove or something that she wears now
permanently so it integrates much
smoother with her body it kind of
becomes a part of
an extension of her body in a much less
mechanical way the subdermal weapon grip
links to our scanner
and shows us weapon information like
ammo count and fire buttons
if i want to be a rough guy then i would
choose something very mechanical looking
whereas if i want to be in high society
i would be choosing something very
stylish think of
your arm being displayed with louis
vuitton
paraphernalia and you can choose a
different style to project a certain
image
thanks again you're the best vic i'm
really amazed
she actually gets an eye implant and an
arm implant within
five minutes she just walks out of there
if i break a leg and i want it reset and
it takes like five minutes that would be
awesome
forced augmentation deus ex human
revolution
so how's it feel being augmented
excuse me don't take it the wrong way i
mean i've got a few neuro enhancements
myself
discreet ones to help me fly better but
i chose to get them implanted
you didn't in this scene um adam jensen
is just recovered from his operations
he was a human um security guard
who got blown up at a terrorist attack
his body was so damaged that he's
let's say 80 percent uh augmented
instead of just being a normal human
this has kind of been forced on him
because he couldn't consent to this
you're right i didn't choose to get
augmented and i still don't know if i
would have if given the choice
but today felt good so he actually needs
these
because otherwise he would die so a lot
of this goes actually back to the idea
of disability
and of norms that we set for what an
abled body is supposed to be doing i
think that's an interesting take on this
um
to put the player into the position of
someone
who didn't want to be augmented but now
needs to be i think the most
outstanding thing about him visually is
the implantation of his eyewear
is actually covered by retractable
mirror shade lenses
there's a 1986 short story collection
called mirror shades by bruce sterling
and in this introduction bruce sterling
actually says that mirror shades make
you look awesome and cool
because they hide the crazy you can't
see the crazy in the people's eyes
so mirror shades is kind of like the
ultimate thing for a cyberpunk
biohacking deus ex mankind divided
in this scene we see rucker who is a
leader for the augmented people he's
being forcibly removed from power by
a targeted attack which eventually kills
him
[Music]
rucker is dead rucker seems to have some
kind of body modification in his head
and he does have two arm prosthesis so
it looks like he actually has human arms
but when they malfunction they kind of
open up and show different
functionalities body modification can be
exploited since it is
a commercial commodification right it's
an it's something you buy from a company
if
for example because of an accident you
have an amputated arm
then obviously replacing that arm with a
body modification actually makes a lot
of sense but replacing
healthy body organs might be risky and
the
possibility of it being hacked might
actually deter you from doing that we
can see this already
in for example self-driving cars which
hackers have been trying to hack and
modify and remote control and
obviously with any technology that is
being run by a computer system
the chance of being hacked is always
possible consciousness
deus ex mankind divided allison
oh [ __ ]
the body is the prison allison is
actually referring to one of the
key ideas of cyberpunk body and mind
are separate from each other the
biological the body
is actually faulty it is limited so she
wants to get rid of the body
leave behind her bodily existence and
kind of become pure data pure
mind pure consciousness and cyberpunk is
referring to
ideas of transhumanism to take
technology
and make us ever smarter ever better the
best version of the best person that we
can be i know what you're doing
i've seen this kind of tech before it
ended badly
pure ignorance of your own people is
contemptible
this is the ascension only our bodies
will die
our minds will leave this cockreal shell
and merge with the divine consciousness
of the machine god this is a part of a
religious
idea of a world beyond our physical
world a virtual afterlife
so there is this utopian moment of this
being paradise but on the other hand it
also is very dystopian in the sense that
if it is computer generated if it is a
virtual world
it also means that it can be hacked you
could actually
reprogram that heaven to become hell
technically
so there is a lot of ambiguity around
this concept and
i for myself don't think i would want my
consciousness uploaded
let's talk about cities in cyberpunk
mega city
ghostrunner
[Music]
seeing this city is actually pretty much
my expectation of
visuals for a cyberpunk city it's night
it is
almost rainy there's fog the city is
very vertical there's
areas beneath me that i can't even see
because of all of the fog and smog going
on
there's areas above me which i can only
imagine where people living in i like
the the dark aesthetics
neon lighting and everything being very
vague and
film noirish and this of course goes all
back to blade runner this is
exactly the kind of image that blade
runner has immortalized as being
cyberpunk one of the aspects that
everybody thinks of when they think of
cyberpunk is
the image of the flying cars which open
blade runner this is
actually picked up here by these rails
which you can hang on to i think it's
very interesting because
if you think of the city as being
vertical then of course
movement on foot is going to be
problematic in order to move from one
place to the other
you have to navigate by flying which
they actually chose very well
here cityscape cyberpunk 2077.
we've greatly enhanced our crowd and
community system
to create the most believable city in
any open world
the city actually takes precedence in
most of these games and it's kind of a
character of its own i like that the
game actually
populates its city with a lot of
different people and
more than most cyberpunk games you can
actually see people from all walks of
life
and i also like the fact that they start
off with showing you the city by day
because most cyberpunk actually plays at
night the city's streets are bustling
with crowds of people
from all facets of life all living their
lives within a full
day and night site i do like the fact
that there is
advertisement everywhere you kind of
have to navigate this space which is
kind of overwhelming at first
the city is actually pretty clean which
is unusual cyberpunk usually goes with
the dirty and gritty
i don't think it's actually a
requirement for a city to be dirty to be
cyberpunk
it probably goes more with the crime but
this seems to be a part of the city that
is actually you know very central it's
kind of a business hub
of some kind so i think it's okay that
it isn't all dirty
i think it's an interesting fact that
everybody seems to be very polite they
actually stop at red lights which i
think is very uncommon for the idea of a
cyberpunk city which is infested with
crime i like the fact that they've
taken their time and kind of constructed
a real city where people
actually do stop at red lights let's see
how governments are represented in
cyberpunk video games
police state deus ex mankind divided
there is um a difference between worlds
and cyberpunk that are still run by
nations and worlds which are run by
corporations but they both basically
have complete militarization of
security work so the idea here is not to
be there to protect and serve but
actually to
be projecting fear projecting control
you have a lot of inequality in these
worlds
there's a lot of conflict around the
idea of police brutality of police
states
you see the police force not in
day-to-day uniforms but you see them
kind of in riot gear they have heavy
equipment
body armor face plates you can also see
this in the drones
they look very military they have
actually weapons on them
so this is a surveillance state this is
a police state that wants to enact
control by show of force for me
cyberpunk is a very political genre so
having political commentary in there and
pointing it out is actually kind of
an important part of reading this
there's a correlation between what
happens in cyberpunk and what happens in
our real world
you could see similar things in the hong
kong protests
where the chinese government put up
forces that looked very military the
hong kong police were stacked out in
riot gear and they
were using facial recognition software
and the protesters were using
masks to mask their facial recognition
so there is a correlation between
cyberpunk
media and activism at the moment
privatization
watchdogs legion with london under
attack by a mysterious terrorist
the government turns to a private
military company called albion to keep
everyone safe
what could possibly go wrong what could
possibly go wrong
when handing over security issues like
police force
to a private company i would ask what
could possibly go right
so if corporations take over state and
national responsibilities
then private security forces become a
commodity for
a specific company what would be their
profit margin
what would be their incentive to do
certain things
this is an issue that we see with the
private prison system in the u.s
if they actually make money per inmate
they
are more incentivized to have more
inmates
so issues like uh public security
um should not be privatized so in this
clip we see police forces that
actually look much more like the police
force we're used to so they're in
uniform
normal clothing they there's very little
riot gear here
or there's less of it than in the
previous clip that we've seen and i
think this is
because the game actually wants to be
closer to our reality it wants to be
more like the world that we know giving
you an authentic feeling of this is how
things could go with the technologies
that we already have
and give you more of a creepy feeling
when these people become exploitative
i find it interesting in this clip that
they've chosen to name the company
albion albion is an old antique name for
the british isles it's interesting to go
back to that reflection of these good
old times when
law and order was provided by knights so
there's this poetic moment to it
naming that albion next let's take a
look at weapons
cyberware cyberpunk 2077
there's a aggressively masculine
tendency in cyberpunk and i think this
actually goes with the idea of these
visceral fight scenes they're using
swords they're using the
mantis blade which of course doesn't
make much sense if you can actually have
railguns
why would you even get close enough to
be using blades but i think it actually
in a game it looks much better
and it's nicer gameplay choosing to use
a weapon that is
implanted has of course the very usual
advantages
in the sense that you can hide the
weapon better it is actually seamlessly
integrated into your arm
so when you're under cover when you're
doing stealth work you could actually
move through recognizable scanners and
so on and just look like you have a
cyber arm
you can now actually you know shoot
someone just by pointing a finger this
is a power fantasy is the idea is you
know you become a weapon
from all of these weapons that they show
you i think of course the
the mantis blade is the one that looks
the most awesome this unfolding of this
blade and the ability to just
you know slash into bodies looks the
most visually impressive
whereas a a cannon in your arm or
something actually seems rather
pedestrian in terms of okay yeah you got
a gun
just this one's hidden in your arm
repossessing cyberware
syndicate upgrade potential detected
in the scene we actually see him
physically removing that
dark chip from the brain which actually
makes a lot of sense because cyberware
is a physical component in your body
it's not
a program being installed or something
but it's actually physically implanted
so you do have mechanical objects
physical objects
actually in the body so in order to get
an implant from the brain you would
probably
have to extract it from the brain but um
i actually like the idea that they're
going for the pg-13 version where some
kind of thingamajig goes in and kind of
pulls it out instead of just chopping
the head up
after he's got the chip he would
probably either install it in himself
so now depending on how the game handles
that he can just implant it into some
kind of socket
or he would have to go to some kind of
underground clinic and get it installed
in the game it usually is just a click
of a button in real life it would
probably be very traumatic procedure to
get this
out and then into yourself and it has
some very
strange hygiene issues and this also has
the second dimension of
body modifications are an expensive
commodity produced by companies so these
companies could actually
offer you lending services instead of
paying twenty thousand dollars for it
up front you could just pay a thousand
dollars for it each month
so what happens if you negate on that
payment
at some point somebody might come and
repossess and recollect
your organs at what point does
technology become
part of that human and at what point is
technology still
seen as an object of technology that can
be repossessed next up
we'll take a look at artificial
intelligence android vs
human detroit become human i know you're
angry daniel
but you need to trust me and let me help
you i don't want your help
nobody can help me i wanted for all this
to stop i
just want all this to stop so the
question of consciousness and of
emotions coming up in
in artificial intelligence is not
restricted to cyberpunk itself it's
actually a theme that has been going on
in science fiction
since metropolis by fritz lang but in
cyberpunk of course this is kind of
also connected to the idea that
machines are essentially objects not
subjects
so who gets to decide how to treat that
other
person that artificial person is uh
actually the owner of that android but i
was wrong
she's just like all the other humans
listen i know it's not your fault
these emotions you're feeling are just
errors in your software
the negotiator is also an android right
so
there's an android talking to an android
trying to get him to release the human
child
for him to refer to emotions as being
errors is of course
programmed into him this goes to the the
idea that
an emotion needs to be an error because
if it was an actual emotion you would
have to grant them personhood if this
android actually could feel emotions
you are mistreating him so there's pain
involved and and suffering and that is
something you need to address
i've spent my life taking orders
now it's my turn to decide
what makes a human is part of the
ultimate problem of cyberpunk and a lot
of cyberpunk actually goes for the easy
route that i've mentioned before which
is transhumanism
and the idea that you can actually
separate the body from the mind
even if i'm 90 metal i'm still a human
because
i still have a human brain i'm still
thinking as a human
but i think that's actually
oversimplification way too much
and some of the best cyberpunk stories
are the ones that completely throw you
off in terms of what makes a person a
person
and it actually means that artificial
intelligence is our person's um it
actually means that
you can become part machine you can meld
with
systems and networks all of these
concepts are kind of going beyond what
we consider human
and i think that's where cyberpunk
actually becomes really interesting
[Music]
what could possibly go wrong
i'm actually one of the first
generations that have grown up with
video games i've been playing video
games
my whole life and i still do it and i
love it also i just love talking about
cyberpunk and science fiction so this
has been a blast
you